okay Charlie yes so Charlie yes so
Charlie is so cool so this is it I guess
a rap challenge that I've been putting
off for so long it's finally here it's
finally here and guess what I still
don't want to do it I just I just don't
think I can do it I think this is just
one challenge too far okay so I'm just
gonna call up my secretary and ask for
another challenge okay because I just
can't I just can't cope with it okay
fine I'll do a rap I hate you all so
much
I'm not gonna pretend that I'm a rapper
because I'm not I'm just a bleep your
brother like sexy feel or been robots I
can't freestyle and my lyrics are not
tonight in fact I think this rappers
taping me two days to white will someone
tell me why I have the urge to do this I
know that you're big stupid but I really
can't resist okay I think I'll stop I
don't want to spray my rest oh you want
me to keep going okay if you insist I
think it's kind of obvious that I'm not
having fun
I've got a headache come over to see my
mum turn off the music on to cup of tea
I want to sit on the sofa and watch the
BBC why the hell don't I choose to do a
rap I think I would prefer if someone
gave me a self would you mind if I took
a little break I'll only be a second I
just want a piece of cake
[Music]
hi I'm back and I've already bored
because this wrapping is a challenge to
which there's no reward I promise I will
never ever do a rapid game the port of
any more of this just makes me go insane
I think I'm gonna stop and go play on my
wii Zelda is the best I think you will
agree this rap is kind of rubbish and I
didn't really try I'll see you tomorrow
good bye okay it's done now let's never
speak of it again
[Music]